[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici en blouse blanche et coiffé d'une
charlotte
et Vanessa ramassent avec précaution les
ufs du jour tout fris pondu oui depuis
depuis 3h ce matin elles ont commencé à
P ben là on ramasse là jusqu'à 11h elle
P et après ça sera l'ouverture des tra
pour pour les poules aller en plein air
depuis 2 mois maintenant ce couple de
leveurs des ha de saint Paul a pris de
nouvelles habitudes chaque matin weekend
et jours fériers compris il do ainsi
ramasser les quelques 7200 ufs de leur
tout premier lot de poule pondeuse le
remassage c'est tous les jours très tôt
très tôt façon de parler c'est à partir
de nous c'est partir de 6h 7h le
ramassage il faut compter minimum 2 à 3
He de temps de ramassage pour les œufs
après c'est de la surveillance après
c'est de faire un tour dans le bâtiment
surveiller regarder contrôler l'eau
l'aliment au niveau des poules si elles
ont pas un problème ou quoi que ce soit
et puis voilà la surveillance de ces
précieuses est en effet constante dans
le poulailler Christian s'assure que ces
poules ne manquent de rien il y a de
l'espace il y a suffisamament d'espace
pour gambader pour jouer par terre il y
a une zone de
grattage audessus son sur k B pour
l'alimentation et
l'eau non non c'est c'est c'est un
bâtiment qui respecte les nouvelles
normes tout ça logiquement il y a pas de
souci avec ce bâtiment tout neuf
répondant au normes de bien-être animal
les poules ont accès à ces pondoirs
adaptés
pour ene tranquillité pondre le
[Musique]
quotien voilà voilà un petit peu le
système du pond quoi pour le ramassage
des ufs pour les poules puissent pondre
en dessous on voit le tapis qui circule
justement avec les ufs pour partir
direction le S pour être ramassé et en
dessous là c'est le N c'est que les
poules ell vont
pourondre tranquillement à
l'intérieur mais c'est bien à
l'extérieur que les poules de Christian
passeront le plus clair de leur temps à
gratter et à picorer sur les 3 hectares
de parcours à leur disposition
oui là elle profite de de la vie de
poule et elle profite du soleil du
bonheur de l'espace et là elle peuvent
gratter
entre parenthèses s'amuser quoi après 3
ans d'études et de concertation
Christian OOT a pu enfin réaliser ce
projet delevage de poule en plein air
grâce à un partenariat avec la Sea du
chemin d'eau également producteur d'œuf
objectif fournir aux consommateurs des
FS plein air pays de qualité ce sont des
œufs qu'on retrouve avec le code 1 donc
le code de production plein air et comme
disait Christian Warot effectivement on
les nourrit avec des graines de lin et
donc on enrichit les œufs avec de
l'oméga 3 et donc régulièrement on
envoie les œufs à l'analyse pour
contrôler le taux d'oméga3 M6 et le
rapport entre les deux elles ont quand
même un joli parcours et une jolie vue
donc je pense que ça ça compte
[Musique]
aussi élevé en plein air dans les haau
de Saint-Paul les poules de Christian
OOT profitent ici de conditions
optimales avec notamment un parcours de
3 haectares pour produire des payi de
qualité côt ramasser les tout FR sont
alors acheminés au centre de
conditionnement situé à Fleurimont où
ils sont
réceptionnés JEP les Avol un par il y a
un sens à mettre et comme ça le dépur
peut prendre dans le bon sens regarde
pas cassé
sont je déjà un premier contrôle visuel
voilétap suiv leôle visuel est renforcé
au de mirage
zéro défaut sur les ufs les ufs Fés les
ufs sales et les US qui sont micro
Fés voilàux qui sont il y en a qui sont
cassés on les enlève directement et ceux
qui sont sales on les laisse passer ils
vont partir dans la première ligne et
ensuite donc tous les ufs vont être
pesés individuellement par un système de
cuillère en fait et on a un ordinateur
qui va mémoriser le poids de chaque œuf
et fonction du PO de chauf on va envoyer
dans telle ou telle ligne et avant de
déposer dans les boîtes on va y inscrire
dessus la traçabilité la date de PTE ces
indications inscrites directement sur la
coquille permettent en effet d'assurer
la traçabilité de l'œuf donc sur les EAU
plein air on a donc on mentionne plein
air la DCR pour date de consommation
recommandée donc c'est 28 jours à partir
de la date de ponte et puis en dessous
vous avez un code européen donc 1 ça
veut dire que les poules sont élevées en
plein air et 3 c'est pour les les poules
élevées en cage après vous avez fr parce
que pour le département la Réunion est
française ensuite vous avez notre code
éleveur donc HC ça correspondinitial de
Monsieur Waro Christian et puis son
numéro du poulailler qui est le
poulailler numéro 1 pour la production
pleinire donc là on a la traçabilité
montante et descendante puisqu'on pourra
remonter à partir de la grande surface
du frigidaire du consommateur jusqu'à
nous et jusqu'à l'élevage de Monsieur
Warot et même au-delà on pourra remonter
jusqu'à à la naissance des pousins à
l'alimentation qui a été distribuée à
une traçabilité totale montante et
descendante à la cadence de 30000 par
heure ce centre conditionne en moyenne
toute catégorie confondue 80000 he par
jour mais ici comme en métropole les
œufs plein air sont de plus en plus
appréciés par les
consommateurs les les gens s'intéressent
de plus en plus à à la qualité de ce
qu'il y a dans leur assiette euh
également au mode de vie des animaux
bien-être animal donc ça c'est des
préoccupations que qui se font jour de
plus en plus et ce qui était à l'époque
il y a quand on a démarré une quinzaine
d'années vraiment une toute petite niche
même si ça reste encore une niche mais
mais la demande progresse petit à petit
l'œuf est seul produit animal
complètement autosuffisant on n'apporte
pas d'œuf à la Réunion d'œuf frais et
donc voilà on joue vraiment la carte de
la proximité de la
fraîcheur
[Musique]